olha só até ali eu tenho uma pergunta
hoje pra vocês
o que você faria se você soubesse que
não fosse falhar e só tem a ver com a
mudança que você não gostaria de ver o
diz é no mundo e à seguinte pergunta é
por que não
o grande medo da falha
esse grande emendou muitas vezes nos
conecta com uma ilusão de que existe um
caminho certo aquele caminho que vai me
levar para o sucesso pra todas as minhas
realizações e eu passo a vida procurando
a portinha que me leva pra esse caminha
pra esse o único caminho que vai
realizar tudo isso eu não achar aí a
coisa fica feia
vocês podem imaginar que eu não concordo
com esta ideia a vida talvez possa ser
algo diferente como seria se eu falar
pra vocês que existem caminhos e que eu
posso fazer eles darem certo que não é
um caminho que ele é um grande caminho e
eu vou fazer o que ele dê certo parece
legal né superbonita
ok eu juro por aqueles que estão aqui
sentados que se eu tivesse pensado nisso
antes eu tenho 40 anos
se tivesses albino antes isso que eu
quero falar pra vocês hoje talvez teria
sofrido menos e com certeza teria me
divertindo mais na vida saber que talvez
aí
nade de construir esse caminho pode não
ser fácil
eu sei que alguns de vocês não está
querendo escolher a carreira que a
escolha de um caminho
e aí tem milhões de opções antigamente
existiam três quatro opções hoje em dia
toma apenas mais de 500 cursos possíveis
e assim como a carreira tem outras
escolhas e pode ser difícil
não existe receita não vou trazer aqui
qual é a fórmula mas eu queria
compartilhar com vocês que existe uma
possibilidade para andar nesse caminho é
não ter que sofrer achar uma pontinha
que ter meu norte
saber que eu quero chegar lá lá no fundo
e aí eu passei por aqui possui por aqui
eu posso às vezes me perdoe mas não sei
que ele pra lá e esse é meu norte e ec
norte
eu vou chamar de propósito divina aquilo
que me move
aquilo que me emociona e faz chorar e
que não se trazendo não vai aparecer só
com um caminho
eu posso ir construindo esse caminho
o meu propósito divina é aquilo que vai
mover que vai me fazer sair do meu lugar
e às vezes sair da minha zona de
conforto e ir em frente
aquilo que me faz gerar mudanças e na
verdade essa coisa pode ser muito
parecendo muito ampla né que quer ser
meu propósito como assim
na verdade uma grande pergunta de quem
sou eu
o que me move na vida mas que pode
parecer uma pergunta muito ambos então
podemos pensar em dividir essa pergunta
o que é o propósito de vida quase como
uma equação matemática com a questão dos
meus talentos
quais são os meus valores igual a
propósito eu sei que eu falei que não
tinha formulado mas às vezes no
desespero uma pequena folha pode ajudar
a gente a continuar andando
então o propósito seria aquilo que eu
vou usar aquelas ferramentas
aqueles talentos que tem o que o trouxe
eu fui desenvolvendo na vida para
realizar aquilo que muito importante pra
mim aquilo que me move e eu amo eu quero
ver no mundo eu quero trazer para o
mundo
às vezes olhar pra quais são os meus
talentos uma pergunta mail difícil
talentos muitas vezes são ouvidos pra
gente e às vezes a gente associa talento
essas coisas grandiosas grandes artistas
tratores jogadores de futebol e com
certeza tem grandes talentos mas talento
também podem ser coisas pequenas e
também são grandiosas
o tinga é um grande jogador de futebol
mas ele tem grandes talentos além da
jogada tenha alma tem a possibilidade de
ter a visão e eu acredito fielmente que
todos nós temos talentos em mais de 1
a idéia é poder se conectar com você
mesmo e poder olhar para você e entender
o que você manda muito bem o que as
pessoas estão dizendo vá em frente é
isso que você sabe às vezes é difícil de
reconhecer porque também temos umas
coisinhas aqui quem fala não isso não
uma vez a gente na treinamentos para
esta reflexão faz um workshop para
pensar para acompanhar as pessoas a se
pensar em que um jovem que eu adorava
uma pessoa super especial ea gente está
neste momento da reflexão de propósito
de talentos ea folha dele está em branco
fazer um tempo e vamos lá vamos entender
o que está passando e perguntei pra ele
que porque não conseguia escrever nada e
ele me disse que ele tinha a certeza de
que não tinha nenhum talento e tudo bem
ele podia fazer algumas coisas mas
talento talento
ele não tinha o que tinha uma resposta
gigantes de coisas que podia falar pra
ele quer em talentos mas ele era ele que
tinha que enxergar isso
então aí a gente começa a conversar ea
gente percebeu que ele tinha tido uma
grande
aplicação na vida que era que ele não
era bom o suficiente
ele tinha um pai muito severo olhava pra
ele rigidamente e que tudo o que ele
fizesse não era bom
nada era suficiente então ele aprendeu
que não era suficiente naquele momento
teria seu muito fácil ele se colocar no
lugar de vítima deserta vem a culpa do
meu pai mas ele queria algo diferente
pra ele ele queria ser protagonista na
sua vida se apropriar do seu caminho e
dizer eu consigo difícil mas eu consigo
então a gente começa a conversar e ele
pediu ajuda e às vezes é a atitude mais
protagonista que a gente pode ter
e começou a perguntar para as pessoas no
que ele era muito bom que ele mandava
vem perguntou pro pai pra mãe do
professor para os amigos e ele se olhou
e se permitiu outra explicação do que
ele era você permite olhar com gratidão
com amora e entender que ele sim tinha
coisas boas e cíntia coisas boas para
entregar pro mundo é de 20 aconteceu
ele achou os seus talentos então essa
pode ser uma reflexão às vezes difícil
às vezes fácil mas com certeza é
importante porque é com isso que eu vou
pro mundo
então voltando pra que ela for bonita
pela folia talentos no que eu sou muito
bom eu vou usar pra aquilo que me move
para aquilo que é muito importante pra
mim
e esses são os meus valores aquilo que
eu amo fazer
tem por trás os valores que me movem que
pode ser o trabalho pode ser um esforço
são inúmeros e essa descoberta
eu só vou fazer olhando para minha vida
observando observando o que é o amor
fazer é de que às vezes me dá raiva
às vezes me faz mexer ou ascensão
adoraria me mexer para poder mudar algo
então se esta reflexão faz algum sentido
para você
em algum momento faz essa pausa olho no
que você é muito bom se permite entender
que tem coisas muito boas
eu posso fazer e olha pra você o que é
muito importante o que você ama o que
você gostaria que fosse diferente e aí
voltando para o começo porque não porque
não usar aquilo que eu sei fazer muito
bem pra mudar aquilo que pra mim é muito
importante
e quer saber de novo nem sempre a gente
vai saber qual é o caminho como fazer
para realizar aquilo pra mim é muito
importante talvez a opção é tentar ir
andando e construindo esse caminho
porque talvez a vida seja a ser e se
aventura que vai pela vida
pesquisando pesquisando sobre si mesmo
se perguntando então que tal uma pausa
para se aliar e se conhecer se conectar
e uma pausa eu sei eu sei que as coisas
do mundo hoje não dá pra pausas que a
gente tem que resolver rápido que a
gente tem que andar mas não uma pausa
para ir para o tibete há um ano e
meditar às vezes eu tenho essa
possibilidade ótimo mas é uma pausa para
as certezas é uma pausa até e saber tudo
eu aprendi há não muito tempo eu
precisava saber para poder andar não
conseguia dar um passo sem saber
exatamente a consequência do que
acontecer
e de repente descobri algo libertador e
era que eu podia andar pra saber e que
não necessariamente só pra saber eu
podia andar pra saber pra sentir e
inclusive pra não saber me fazer
perguntas quantas vezes têm perguntas
que nos transformam
que nos guiam o sistema não está
preparando pra isso
quem recebeu uma boa nota para uma boa
pergunta
em geral a gente está condicionado a dar
boas respostas e não boas perguntas mas
tem uma boa pergunta pode abrir caminhos
incríveis não ter que saber tudo nos
abre a possibilidade de aprender
aprender de mim aprender do mundo
aprender da vida aprender a não saber
aprender a se perder
faz dois anos eu fui fazer um curso
maravilhoso
lá no chile de coaching ontológico e
isso ia ser algo é um caminho que não
sabia se a dar certo e não tinha certeza
mas tinha a ver com o meu norte
eu não sabia de quanto a transformação
ea série e fui lá no avião eu levei um
livro então isso livrou mais bonita que
eu já lhe chamava teatro da carência de
um clown suíço que chama daniel fim de
pasta ela tinha uma frase quase no
finalzinho do livro que daniel fala
assim na vida aí que aprender a perder
se para aprender a encontrar se na vida
a gente tem que aprender a se perder
para aprender a se encontrar
ok gostei grifei fechar meu livro chega
em santiago por volta das dez e meia da
noite pegou uma van foi pro meu hotel da
van
olho para o renan só prédios de
escritório
nada de hotel e pensar no que aconteceu
é que eu me liguei
eu peguei o endereço que estava no e
mail da moça com que eu troquei médio
para fazer a reserva e eu não tinha me
ligado que talvez a moça não estava no
hotel e que ela ficava no escritório que
era lá na rede de hotéis e que não eram
endereçam do meu hotel
então eu percebi que era 11 da noite
eu estava no meio de santiago
perdida olhou para o céu
deu uma risadinha e falei para o meu
amigo destino
ok eu entendi a vida essa possibilidade
da gente se perder e se encontrar e pra
gente se encontrar
temos que olhar pra dentro estar
conectados com nós mesmos
muito obrigado